what is evil
is this a word you avoid
no
i don't
because i think part of what we're
wrestling with here is resisting the
enlightenment i mean the historical
period in europe
the idea that
evil and sin can just be reduced to
immorality
um
individual human immorality
i think there's something deeper
in the idea of sin than just immoral i
think sin is a much more comprehensive
category i think sin is
a failure to love wisely so that you
ultimately
engage in a kind of idolatry
you take something as ultimate which is
not
and that can tend to constellate
these collective agents i call them
hyper agents within distributed
cognition that have a capacity to wreak
havoc on the world
that is not just due to a sort of a sum
total
of immoral decisions i mean you know
this goes to hannah arendt's thing right
and the banality of eichmann and she was
really wrestling with it and i think she
she's close to something but i think
she's slightly off you know eichmann is
just making a whole bunch of immoral
decisions but it doesn't seem to capture
the gravity
of what the nazis did the genocide and
the warfare and and she's right because
you're not going to get just the
summation of a lot of individual rather
banal
immoral choices adding up to what was
going on you're getting a comprehensive
parasitic process within massive
distributed cognition that is has the
power to confront the world and confront
aspects of the world that individuals
can't and i think when we're talking
about evil
that's what we're trying to point to
this is a point of convergence between
me and jonathan pajot we've been talking
about this so the word sin is
interesting yes are you comfortable
using the word sin
because it's so deeply rooted in
religion it is it is and in part and and
and i struggle around this um
because i was brought up as a
fundamentalist christian and so that is
still
there within me there's trauma
associated with that
probably uh
layers of self-deception mechanisms
no doubt no doubt that you're slowly
escaping trying to and trying to come
into a
proper respectful relationship
uh with christianity via a detour
through buddhism taoism and pagan
neoplatonism trying to find a way how to
love wisely yes exactly and so i want to
i think this the term sin is good
because
somebody may not be doing something that
we would prototypically call immoral
but
if they're failing to love wisely
they are
disconnecting themselves
in some important way
from the structures of reality
and
i think i think it was hume i may be
wrong he says you know people don't do
things
because they think it's wrong they do a
lesser good in place of a greater good
and that's a different thing than being
immoral i mean we're all we're saying oh
you're doing something that's wrong it's
like well no no
you know i'm loving my wife that's a
great thing isn't it
yeah but if you love your wife at the
expense of your kids
like ah maybe something's going awry
here right well i love my country great
but should you love your country at the
expense of your commitment to the
religion you belong to like people
should wrestle with these questions
and i think sin is a failure to wrestle
with these questions
properly yeah to be content with the
choices you've made without considering
yeah um
is there a greater good that could be
done
you